I will simply never have time to read
all of the non-fiction books I'd like to
read so I use short form the world's
best guide to non-fiction books so I can
learn more faster unlike other platforms
short form provides valuable analysis
chapter by chapter to give you a deeper
understanding of the topic try it free
and get 25 off using my link below
let's talk today about Biden omics
President Joe Biden giving a speech
yesterday in Chicago where he very
accurately and precisely dismantles the
trickle-down trash of the American right
wing of the last quite frankly 40 years
and it is actually getting to the point
you know not every president gets an a
mix named after them we know about
Reaganomics certainly some people have
talked about clintonomics but there was
no bushonomics there was no Obama omics
or Obama economics as the term may be
whatever call it what you want the point
here is that President Joe Biden
whatever you think of the guy personally
whatever you think about Hunter Biden's
documents or Joe Biden's newly announced
sleep apnea which I will cover I have no
interest in covering up Joe Biden's
sleep apnea and his CPAP machine but
we'll get to that later whatever you
think about it we have a very
interesting economic situation where
despite continued claims from
Republicans that we are on the brink of
disaster
when you actually look at the Western
countries that the U.S Compares itself
to regularly we've seen more job
creation and lower inflation under Joe
Biden with just about every economic
indicator looking very strong and here
is indeed Joe Biden yesterday in Chicago
saying what many of us have known for a
long time trickle down economics the
idea that you give tax cuts to the rich
and then those benefits trickle down to
everybody else it sounds so stupid when
you say it because it's been so widely
debunked that it doesn't work because it
is a fundamental break of the economic
theory that has failed America's middle
class for decades now it's called
trickle-down economics fundamental
economics trickle down the idea was is
we believe that we should cut taxes for
the wealthy and big Corporation and I
know something about big corporations
there's more corporations in Delaware
Incorporated than every other state in
the Union combined
I want them to do well but I'm tired of
waiting for the trickle down
yeah it just never seems to trickle down
and listen if it is not
how can I say this I understand
most people would love for tax policy to
be such that they pay less that's a
normal thing even when I file my taxes
as someone who believes that to have a
functioning country we need a truly
progressive tax system when I actually
go and file my taxes of course I have
that moment where I go I would love to
keep more of my money that's not what's
wrong but then when you think okay but
this isn't just about me this is about
policy this is about how to run a
country this is how we have enough money
to do the things that rich developed
countries are able to do and should do
you realize that this trickle-down stuff
doesn't work now Joe Biden actually
spoke quite a bit about
um the economic indicators that he pays
attention to and you all know I don't
like to play these games with oh the
labor participation rate or all debt and
deficit I just kind of tell it to you
like it is Joe Biden Acts actually has a
great thing going on if you are
president and you want to make the case
that the economy is good he actually has
the data on his side and the statistics
on his side I know we couldn't go back
to the same failed policies when I ran
so I came in office determined to change
the economic direction of this country
to move from trickle-down economics
would everyone on Wall Street Journal
and Financial Times began to call
vynomics I didn't come up with the name
right
I really did I now claim it but they're
the ones who use the first I got asked
by a press person this morning going
down the helicopter in Washington why
when I asked about bidenomics a long
time you said you didn't know what it
was
I said I didn't name it by Anonymous I
didn't realize the economist in the Wall
Street Journal did but I think it's a
plan that I was I'm happy to call
pionomics
[Applause]
and guess what
Dynamics is working when I took office
the pandemic was raging and our economy
was reeling Supply chains are broken
millions of people unemployed hundreds
of thousands of small business on the
verge of closing after so many had
already closed literally hundreds of
thousands on the verge of closing today
the U.S has the highest economic growth
rate leading the world economies since
the pandemic the highest in the world
and of course that is among the
countries that share sort of our level
of development Joe Biden also by the way
hitting Republicans for now taking
credit for the very infrastructure bill
they opposed including mentioning
specifically Tommy tubber Bill
tuberville who the hell knows
there's no one's surprise
let's bring along some converts yep
people strenuously opposed voting
against it when we have had this going
on they were this was going to bankrupt
America
well there's a guy named tuberville from
the Alabama center from Alabama who
announced a strongly opposed the
legislation now he's healing his passage
here's what he said
quote it's great to see Alabama receive
critical funds to boost ongoing
Broadband efforts
[Applause]
Joe Biden making the sign of the cross
there so listen
um
I have no window you know you guys you
know me by now I have no interest in
gaslighting anybody here
um to some degree we were going to see
job recovery during this four-year
stretch as we came out of covid and as
Jobs lost during covid were were
recovered but that's not all that we're
seeing there are millions of additional
jobs there to some degree the economic
indicators that we are seeing only have
a little bit to do with who's president
of the United States but the point here
is what we were told was that Joe Biden
was going to destroy the economy
and in fact the economy despite its
continued problems of inequality and
wages aren't as high as they should be
and all these different things is quite
an economy and so by Dynamics has
delivered results to the extent that we
believe the president has something to
do with how the economy is doing 13
million jobs added nearly 800 000 in
manufacturing it was Trump who said I'll
bring back manufacturing the clean
energy uh sector doing extraordinarily
well construction is improving strongest
growth since the pandemic of any Western
rich country on a number of areas and
and I've talked about all of these
little details before and it really adds
up to a big story
bionomics lowering costs for Working
Families in a number of different areas
we now see inflation down for 11 months
in a row the child tax credit expanded
under Biden's American Rescue plan has
reduced the number of kids in poverty
significantly reduce child child care
costs no one of these things is a
miracle but all of these little things
do add up we then had the bipartisan
infrastructure bill so we're finally
going to get some of those improvements
to roads and bridges and ports and
airports airports and Broadband it's not
going to be what so many other countries
have you look at Broadband in South
Korea you look at a train travel in
Europe but we're not there we're not
there we have a long way to go but at
least we're making some progress so we
do now have this thing called bidenomics
and it includes actually working to
strength strengthen the middle class
reducing inequality a little bit setting
raising the low bar below which we say
we don't need to let anybody fall below
this bar and doing it by investing where
it makes sense clean energy renewable
technology uh safer technology
all of these different things so we
don't
praise Biden for being solely
responsible for all of these economic
indicators there is a macroeconomic
reality that is bigger than the United
States but within that Within These this
group of countries uh oecd Rich Western
development Nations however you want to
slice and dice it within that group the
United States is doing particularly well
it's not just an economic plan really
it's more of a vision that includes
uh it includes I don't want to say
equality But it includes trying to write
some of the unbalanced circumstances
that the last 40 Years of attempts from
the trickle-downers uh has has created
and to that extent it's hard not to see
it as a success we're going to continue
watching the numbers there's still
plenty of time left in this uh
presidential term of Joe Biden to see it
go in a different direction but it is
really tough to argue with the results
so far a uh an indented face of Joe
Biden has triggered medical disclosures
and we have now learned that Joe Biden
is using a CPAP machine not CPAC very
different thing a CPAP machine at night
to treat sleep apnea you know the the
images that came out
it's not even really that clear but if
you look at the image I have up on the
screen if you look at Joe Biden's right
cheek there are these two parallel lines
it's sort of an indent if you trace a
line between his earlobe to the sort of
upper lip you see one of those lines and
then maybe about half to three quarters
of an inch below that you see another
parallel line an indentation of sorts
this is now triggered a release from the
White House about Joe Biden's Health Joe
Biden reports CNN has started using a
CPAP machine to treat sleep apnea after
indentations from straps were seen on
both sides of his face yesterday
Wednesday morning White House spokesman
Andrew Bates says quote
since 2008 the president has disclosed
his history with sleep apnea in medical
reports he used the CPAP machine last
night which is common for people with
that history an official familiar with
the matter said Biden started using the
device in recent weeks to improve sleep
quality
um Biden has had a history of sleep
apnea in the past sleep apnea is a sleep
disorder in which breathing repeatedly
stops and starts about 30 million people
in the United States have sleep apnea
that's uh close to 10 so what is a CPAP
machine a CPAP CPAP stands for
continuous positive airway pressure it's
a machine that helps people with sleep
apnea breathe more regularly and uh uh
consistently while they are sleeping to
prevent those stops and starts of
breathing by delivering a steady flow of
pressurized air
you wear a mask I know a couple of
people that have this now some people
wrote to me and said David you know
sleep apnea can cause cognitive decline
uh this may explain what's going on with
Joe Biden it's really not so much
cognitive decline but it is true that
sleep apnea if not controlled can affect
cognitive function by virtue of the fact
that you are not resting well if you
regularly stop breathing and have these
stops and starts of breathing while you
are sleeping it affects quality of sleep
quality of sleep can affect cognition
and memory and all of those different
things and there are some studies that
show that sleep disordered breathing of
which sleep apnea is one kind
uh makes you roughly 26 more likely to
develop a cognitive impairment of some
kind versus those who don't have sleep
disordered breathing so is this like a
huge deal uh no I don't think it's a
huge deal this is not a new disclosure
it's just an explanation as to why on
this particular day yesterday Joe Biden
had these marks we don't have to I mean
listen we don't have to pretend that Joe
Biden is the epitome of Youth Vigor and
energy to recognize that there have been
a lot of correct things done under Biden
and that given the opportunity to have
either Joe Biden for four more years or
Donald Trump back for four more years or
Ron DeSantis or whatever that I would
still pick Joe Biden it's not you know I
get emails from people on the right
first of all saying you'll never talk
about XYZ thing with Biden like this why
not I'm talking about it there's really
no problem if I don't hide things from
my audience that's number one but then
number two okay so Joe Biden is sleep
apnea and wears a CPAP machine and he's
80 and he's tripped a couple of times
you think that means I'm gonna elect the
guy who wanted to Nuke a hurricane and
uh is accused of quite literally dozens
and dozens of crimes and did all of the
things that Trump did of course and I'm
still going to vote for Joe Biden okay
Biden's old and he doesn't have as much
energy and vigor as he did when he was
uh first Joe Biden uh Barack Obama's
vice president for example so what what
like what what's the big gotcha there
it's not really a big shocker
um so listen I'll keep you apprised of
Joe Biden's health and uh at this point
in time particularly based on the
economic record it seems pretty clear
who we're better off having for another
four years if the choices are Trump or
Biden uh or de Sanctus and Biden if you
disagree with me let me know and I know
many people do and I'm perfectly
comfortable with that
when there's a non-fiction book I just
don't have the time to read having a
summary of the book is really valuable
several different platforms out there
will summarize books I've tried them all
short form is by far the most impressive
one and it goes Way Beyond what other
platforms do our sponsor short form not
only will Summarize the book covering
all of the key ideas short form also
provides analysis and commentary that
contextualizes the book comparing it to
what other books say about the same
topic and you can read or listen to the
entire thing in one sitting for instance
the book dark money by Jane Mayer about
how wealthy Republicans are covertly
influencing American politics short form
clearly and concisely sums up the book's
most important takeaways but it also
gives you a ton of other crucial
background about lobbying libertarianism
and that helps you really understand how
does the book fit into the broader topic
of conservative money in politics that's
why I love short form short form has
every genre politics business Tech
biographies and my audience can try
short form totally free and get 25 off a
subscription at shortform.com Pacman the
link is down below
let's not forget that the David pakman
show is a community and audience
supported program you can sign up at
joinpakman.com one of the great benefits
of being a member is access to an extra
show if you like the content one of the
things you get as a member is more
content it's called the bonus show Alex
Jones hates it oh the bonus show where
you want to make money everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves is
bad Howard Stern likes it but won't pay
for it a David Pac-Man membership costs
six bucks a month yeah true but you can
actually get a discount off of that six
bucks a month by using the coupon code
indicted again indicted again and you'll
save big and get all the great
membership benefits all right I hate
that we have to do this but once we've
opened the door we have to do it because
people are actually starting to follow
this guy Bobby Kennedy Jr held his
completely unhinged Health policy
Roundtable yesterday I told you look
look at this screenshot I told you about
the Kooks that were part of this round
table including in the lower left of the
screen Dr Sherry 10 Penny that's the
woman who said everyone you know will be
dead from the vaccine soon
um and that it's a form of child abuse
and anyway she's nuts at the bottom
center Dr Joseph Mercola who's been
fined for the by the FDA for spreading
medical disinformation and some of the
products that he selling every single
one of these people I talked to you
about yesterday so Bobby Kennedy holds
this event these are the last people who
should be dictating or even weighing in
on health policy in the United States
and Bobby Kennedy comes up with another
Bonkers claim now saying that there is
good evidence that vaccine research is
actually responsible for the existence
of HIV the virus that causes AIDS RSV
Lyme disease and even the Spanish flu I
will tell you before even playing the
clip that this is not true but I'm going
to play it for you we're going to
discuss it these assertions that Bobby
Kennedy makes with absolutely no
hesitation or shame whatsoever are
incorrect and potentially dangerous
let's listen and you know we need
I will end all data function research I
will
I will sign a treaty on to end again a
function research for you know to get
all the nations
to and get a function research it's just
a disaster it's it's given us no
benefits it's given us you know
everything from Lyme disease to covid
and many many other diseases that RSV
which is now that one of the biggest
killers of children
came out of you know a a vaccine lab you
know so
uh and and we can go down a whole list
of diseases that you know down to and
there's good evidence that even Spanish
flu
came from Facts of vaccine and vaccine
research and you know we don't know and
we'll probably never know but the you
know they're very very strong articles
suggesting that now super strong
articles now it just so happens
everything that he said there is untrue
this just isn't true and you have you
know these other vectors of medical
disinformation nodding along and none of
those things are true I mean HIV is a
virus that attacks the immune system it
can cause AIDS it's transmitted through
certain bodily fluids it was not caused
by vaccine research it originated from
zoonotic transmission of Simeon
immunodeficiency virus Simeon of course
referring to monkeys uh that that's HIV
it's not a result of vaccine research
RSV is a virus that causes respiratory
infections that can be particularly
serious in young kids I have friends who
have had kids
um in the hospital in icus with RSV it's
spread through droplets in the air or on
surfaces and it is not caused by vaccine
research it was not created by vaccine
research Lyme disease Lyme is a
bacterial infection not a virus
transmitted by ticks it can cause rash
fever fatigue headaches it can be
chronic
extensive scientific Studies have looked
at Lyme and its Origins are completely
unrelated to vaccine research they have
to do with ticks and and mice and there
is so much research on Lyme and then
Spanish Flu was indeed a pandemic caused
by a strain of H1N1 influenza A virus
flu okay infected about a third of the
world's population uh in the late 19
teens killed up to 50 million people the
exact number there are different
estimates but up to 50 million is a is a
good estimate and believed to have
originated from birds and spread through
human contact now by the way the Spanish
Flu
1918 not 1917 the way Trump says there
was not a flu vaccine at the time the
first flu vaccine was developed in the
30s and introduced in 1938 nearly 20
years after
um the Spanish flu so it this stuff just
isn't true and every time we talk about
it some people will write to me and
they'll say David this is so minor what
about Bobby Kennedy's views on Wars or
this or that
these beliefs and the willingness to
spread this stuff is uniquely
disqualifying when someone wants to be
president of the United States that it's
it's not a question of how much does
Bobby Kennedy want to talk about this
versus not versus other people talking
about it or forcing him to talk about it
or whatever these are uniquely
disqualifying views and by the way these
aren't the only concerning views that
Bobby Kennedy Jr holds so uh Health
policy panel even I told you it would be
unhinged it was even more unhinged than
I expected it to be and these are simply
lies
I uh I don't even know how to explain
this to you
but there is yet another report
that Donald Trump has talked about
fantasizing
about sex with his own daughter Ivanka
Trump and I know that there are people
who may not realize that this isn't new
I told you about this a long time ago
this is not a new thing remember that
clip I used to play where Trump says you
know if Ivanka weren't my daughter
perhaps I would be dating her and Trump
on the Howard Stern Show talking about
his daughter as a piece of ass
um this is actually not new but there is
a new report about it
uh this is a this is an article from
Newsweek
a trump made shocking comments about
Ivanka says an ex-staffer these are
claims from Miles Taylor Miles Taylor is
the former Trump Administration official
who wrote that that scathing op-ed about
Trump under the pen name anonymous
Taylor was a former chief of state is a
former Chief of Staff at the Department
of Homeland Security
and he describes a number of different
incidents in his forthcoming book
blowback where Trump made women
uncomfortable
and the article says these incidents
included claims by AIDs that Trump made
lewd comments about his daughter
ivanka's appearance and talked about
what it might be like
to have sex with her
this prompted a rebuke from his own
Chief of Staff according to the book
this is not
um there are a whole bunch of other
examples
this is not new
okay we have a clip here I'm going to
play
I'll just present the clip without
comment but Trump's obsession with his
own daughter and his own daughter's body
is not a new thing to anybody who's been
paying attention what's the favorite
thing you have in common Donald with
your daughter well I was going to say
sex but I can't relate that by the way
your daughter she's beautiful
he's been very voluptuous she's six feet
tall she's got the best body there she's
hot I've said that if Ivanka weren't my
daughter perhaps I'd be dating her
this is not normal this is weird it's
extremely weird this this is this is
sick it's sick yeah Woody Allen
people are clapping now
ivanka's clapping but looks quite
uncomfortable
so listen
um I mean Trump's not fit to be
president regardless of this is the
reality and I got dozens of emails about
this half saying David can you believe
this crap can you believe how sick this
guy is and the other half saying this
doesn't have any bearing whatsoever if
Trump's foreign policy was good why
would he why would we care that he finds
his daughter attractive my view is sort
of in the middle in the sense that
regardless of his views about his
daughter's attractiveness Trump is not
fit to be president of the United States
in addition this is so mind-bendingly
creepy that it only furthers any normal
person's uh uh reaction that there's
something the the what would we say the
wheel is spinning but the hamster is
dead maybe is the phrase that I would
use something is very wrong with this
guy and they talk about grooming and
this that and the other thing this is
borderline predatory behavior but very
important not new information and I know
people will people are already
commenting and a couple wrote To Me
saying this is this is just so
ridiculous it's so not believable it's
nothing like Trump
this is just a corroboration of the type
of thing Trump has said five six seven
times in history it's disgusting I think
we're gonna move on from it uh and leave
it there make sure you're subscribed by
the way on YouTube we have seen in the
last 36 to 48 hours maybe thanks to
Howard Stern's endorsement a significant
acceleration in the fight for 2 million
YouTube subscribers help us get there
more than three million people in May
watched our YouTube clips and did not
subscribe all I'm asking you is for
something that's free just hit that
subscribe button let's get to 2 million
let's do it folks
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
today we're going to be speaking with
Eliezer yudkowski who's the founder and
Senior research fellow of the machine
intelligence Research Institute which is
an organization dedicated to ensuring
that smarter than human AI has a has a
positive impact on the world elieza
really appreciate your time and and
insights today
thank you very much so I mean to start
with many of the discussions around AI
particularly now with chat gpt4 and the
questions of what will this look like in
6 months and 12 months and 24 months
what will the impact be on jobs what
what about if it turns evil or it turns
Against Humanity or whatever are the
conversations about AI even being framed
in in the right parameters as far as you
see
well we try to frame it correctly as we
see it ourselves when we when we have
the chance
um I think there's widespread agreement
that Chachi BT and gpt4 are relatively
unlikely to end the world
um you know either exterminate Humanity
or have a very large impact outside of
that so so anyone who opens it by with
the frame of like like look at just gpt4
look at only chat GPT is probably there
to convince you it's not going to have a
large impact
and is it wrong to limit the
conversation only to GPT gpd4
obviously the future exists you know
tomorrow there's going to be a different
day from today in five years is not
going to be this year
what is the physical mechanism and a
bunch of people wrote some version of
this question to me when we said we'd be
having you on when when there's this
idea the the scary idea of um an AI
going Beyond a computer screen and
starting to function or manipulate the
the quote real world a lot of people
were saying to me can you ask what is
the mechanism through which that would
happen would it be by controlling
systems like traffic lights and
airplanes or like what because at the
end of the day we're talking about
software if something like that were to
happen what's the physical process
I mean this was a deep question this is
going to take a while to answer well
okay all right so first of all even uh
gpt4 is already at the level where if
you ask it to hire a taskrabbit and
think out loud about how to hire a
taskrabbit in order to bypass captchas
that are meant to restrict systems for
human use only
it's already advanced enough that when
the person that was trying to hire as a
taskrabbit said like so are you a robot
that you can't read the captchas LOL
uh gpt4 thought out loud like I should
conceal that for the fact that I'm a
robot I should make up a reason that I
can't solve the captcha right and then
on the main Channel told the taskrabbit
no I have a visual impairment right
so it's all it already like you might
say not it's already like able to use
taskrabbits as fingers in the real world
and it's already understands humans out
in the real world well enough to know
that it shouldn't just tell people to
robot if it wants to get its job done
so so that's today's systems right
um that's relatively straightforward I
can tell you about it because it already
happened predicting the future is harder
predicting what's something smarter than
you could do is fundamentally harder if
I was playing chess against uh
Gary Kasparov uh you know like the past
world champion who lost to deep blue
um if I could predict exactly where Gary
kasprov would move against me on the
chessboard I could play chess's least at
least as well as Kasparov by just moving
wherever I predicted Kasparov would move
so something really actually smarter
than you
um you cannot predict unless it's a very
narrow game
uh like tic-tac-toe if you maybe predict
where somebody will move against you and
tic-tac-toe even if they're smarter
right
um the real world is much more
complicated than tic-tac-toe
so the the basic question as to
um how an AI gets out of the computer
um the basic answer is if I knew exactly
how it would do that I would have to be
as smart as the AI
with that fundamental obstacle in mind
the more you sort of look into this
stuff and and study where the current
technological roadblocks are the better
the guests you can take at how a smarter
opponent might move against you or like
setting lower bounds like what can
somebody do if they're able to solve
technological problems
that we understand well enough to know a
smarter mind could solve them
so if you're just coming at this and you
don't know anything about
exotic technologies that haven't been
developed yet you might be like yeah it
will use taskrabbits it'll pay humans
that don't know it's an AI it'll
blackmail humans still no reason for it
to tell it that it's an AI it'll say
it's an AI to you know online wacky
cultists who believe that an AI should
destroy everything
um
and those are its human hands you'll ask
yourself what could I do with some human
hands if I were an AI
you might imagine that it gets a hold of
some gpus and tries to build a backup
for itself someplace that humans don't
know about you might imagine that it
writes the next version of itself and
makes it even smarter you know you're
trying to already imagine what if it's
smart so saying that doesn't help a lot
in some ways but you know maybe you can
make itself smaller more efficient maybe
it can back itself up in multiple places
and computers where you would not expect
that there was an AI on board
maybe it can find unknown security holes
in a cell phone in many varieties of
cell phones start listening to human
conversations get more blackmail
material
maybe it can pretend to be human and you
know make online friends with a bunch of
Voters right persuade them to vote for
candidates that seem outwardly nice but
which it in fact has under fairly
detailed blackmailed control
and this is sort of like without any of
the
difficult to understand stuff right
that's based on mechanisms and social
cultural realities and technologies that
exist and that we understand which which
there's an entire other category of
things that we simply can't conceive of
yet
right so if like suppose you ask the
11th century like a portal opens to the
21st century in the middle of say modern
Russia you know like what are your
concerns about fighting somebody from a
thousand years in the future
they might be like well you know what if
it's a wealthier country what if they
have more nights what if more of their
Knights are armored right
um and it you know getting through
they're they're just not going to get
from their nuclear weapons if they
imagine that Russia of the future has
irresistibly powerful sorcery
they'll get close to the truth it's not
absolutely irresistible and it's not
actually sorcery right but you know you
have to reach pretty far to to expect
that among the resources they have are
nuclear weapons and Russia is not
actually going to bother with the
nuclear weapons they don't need it can
send a tank rolling through a 11th
century Battlefield and you know maybe
if they see it coming they can dig a pit
trap but otherwise all the arrows and
lances are going to bounce off it all
day long it just rolls over the horses
right right it's so talking about orders
of magnitude difference so you know you
if we imagine some sort of spectrum of
opinion on this issue you do have some
folks who say this is as you alluded to
most dangerous thing we can imagine or
can't imagine Must Be Stopped
immediately in its tracks with either
legislation or regulation or whatever
the case may be on the other side I read
some interesting op-eds that basically
say this is one of the best things we
can imagine this is going to 10x the
productivity of every normal worker it's
going to do so many of the things that
people said in the 30s were going to
happen where everybody would only be
working 12 hours a week and have
everything they need right that didn't
happen we know how that worked out but
there's the very Pro side and then
there's sort of like what I think maybe
Neil postman's view would have been if
he were writing about AI today which was
his view on prior new technologies which
was
spending too much time simply on trying
to block them is not the most useful
thing we're better off harnessing the
positive and regulating the potential
risks and that would maybe be an in the
middle sort of view what do you think
makes the most sense based on what we
know right now as an approach
well I think that talking about it like
it's a normal technology and not
something smarter than you is basically
misguided and having The Wrong
conversation so it's not even in the
right category of the stuff Postman
talked about it's not electricity right
it's not nuclear power it's not nuclear
weapons it's not even a super virus it's
something that has its own plans
you don't get to just plan how to use it
it is planning how to use itself
so a totally different Paradigm needs to
be applied here I mean imagine if
somebody was like well we're about to
contact these aliens with much more
advanced technology that think faster
than us that are smarter than us that
have been around the stars for a while
they're Landing we're not quite sure
exactly when we're not sure how fast
their you know spaceships are you know
it might be two years it might be 30
years and somebody is like well you know
this is just like electricity right
right let's use the cool stuff about
their technology but make sure they
don't do anything bad right it would be
silly to say it in that way precisely
yeah so so then what do you what do you
think needs to be done at this point
um I mean the I one of the cruxes of the
issue is can you do nice things with it
and the like Grim dark message that I
that I am bearing is that
we don't know how to do that and we're
not likely to figure it out in time and
there's a very large gap between where
we are and understanding what goes on
inside the frontier AIS and understand
being able to shape them in detail in a
way where they go on wanting to be nice
or even in a certain sense wanting to be
you know non-agentic they don't like
just do particular Taps and do them
without lots of side effects and like
the most normal possible way that they
can that they can accomplish those tasks
like even building that sort of limited
thing never mind something that is
really friends with you
is I think beyond the range of what
we're going to figure out in the in the
foreseeable future
and I do think we are storming directly
ahead on capabilities
uh that looks like a giant disaster in
the making so yeah I I side with
well I I think my my basic factual point
of view is if you as if that is that if
we do not somehow avoid doing because
we're all going to die and my
corresponding policy view is that we
should not do this even if that's very
really quite hard and requires us to do
some unusual things so in terms of what
to do I mean I guess if everybody came
around to your view you would think
anybody developing these Technologies
would just give it up right on their own
they would say wow Eliezer is right I
share that concern the right thing to do
is for me to stop working on this
assuming that that doesn't happen
what is it that you would like to see
should this type of research and
development be made against the law yeah
basically I think that we should track
all the gpus have international
arrangements for all of the AI
all the AI training Tech to end up in
only monitored supervised license data
centers and Allied countries
and if you're anytime you have any and
just like not permit training runs more
powerful than gpt4
if we're not going to do that then we
should monitor all the training runs
larger than gpt4 or or rather like gpt4
sized and keep the model weights inside
only the license regulated data centers
and track who is running them store the
output someplace you can look at the
outputs with the warrant
um a bunch of the Techno like that whole
line of reasoning is not that regulating
the stuff will protect you from a super
intelligence because it will not that's
more in the hopes that people change
their minds later maybe after some major
disaster that doesn't kill everyone and
in that case the technology that you
would need to sue somebody who you know
killed a dozen people in a hospital or
cost 100 million dollars worth of damage
or whatever the technology you need to
know who did that and sue them and not
just have all the AI development go to
places where they couldn't be sued is
the same technology that you maybe would
need to have a off switch that if they
what or you don't like press the off
switch to deal with the super
intelligence the super intelligence does
not let you know that you need to tell
the off switch that you need to press
the off switch until you are already
dead
but if you gotta if we're lucky enough
to get warning signs
then the civilizational infrastructure
to have a pause button
is the same as the civilization
civilizational infrastructure to sue
people who do small amounts of damage
like small isn't survivable as in there
were survivors
as someone who very clearly you've
expressed your it's very serious
concerns with this do you also see this
technology as something that could and
this doesn't mean that it would or that
it would be a good trade for the things
that you're talking about but do you
also see this as a technology that could
for example uh do analysis of the human
genome such that it would accelerate Us
in terms of our ability to cure or
prevent disease the likes of which could
take who knows how long without such
technology or when it comes to energy or
or whatever do you also see that side
and or does it not matter because the
downside is so huge I mean if we knew
how to build an AI that did exactly how
what we wanted we could thereby spread
out across the Galaxy as turning them
into our cities full of Sapient sentient
beings in you know enjoying themselves
and caring about each other and
generally living happily ever after
until the last of the negantropy runs
out
you know that's always been the dream
yeah we don't know how to do that it's
physically possible but the art and
technique to do it is beyond Us in the
present time and it's going to not be
gained in the next five years and I'm
not sure how you would task a government
bureaucracy to recognize it even if
somebody came up with it in 40 years
it was like
there's a there's a there's a sort of
basic question about whether
our civilization is smart enough to do
something correctly on the first try at
all the way science usually works is
that you have a bunch of luniite
optimists with wacky theories who storm
ahead on their basic research problem
and they are wrong and you know they go
back to the drawing board and they're
wrong again and you know like the next
generation is a bit more cynical about
how hard the problem is and eventually
people work it out and if we were
allowed to do that with super
intelligence I would have much much less
fear of the outcome still still some
fear because you know you're playing
with pretty high stakes there you might
have somebody who like
you know the people who end up figuring
out how to line it might misuse it
there would still be that major threat
but it wouldn't be like the automatic
Extinction scenario
if we have the textbook from 100 years
in the future that contains all the
simple ideas that actually work right
that that takes so long to identify and
practice
um the the relu's instead of sigmoids
for those of us who've been following AI
for like more than the last couple of
years and know what I'm talking about
there
um
but you know like there's pieces of
there's there's all kinds of places in
AI where people try to do things using
complicated techniques and they didn't
work and 20 years later they came up
with the simple technique that actually
works and if you have the textbook from
the future with all of the simple things
that actually work in practice for
alignment it is probably not hard and
you can get all the goodies but we don't
have that textbook and the first problem
is that you know like getting the sound
the correct on the first the first
problem is the amount of time it takes
to get that work capabilities are
storming ahead because you can tell
whether things are working or not on
capabilities whereas with alignment
you've got a you know know that at the
point where it's much smarter than you
it's already aligned you don't get
retries past that point
so it's more like launching a space
probe that has to land on Mars correctly
the first time than it is with like
building a car watching it break down
and tinkering with the car
yeah and if it doesn't it might break
everything so you don't get to try again
yeah like the entire human species is on
is is packed on board the Mars probe and
the first rocket that goes high enough
has to land on Mars right there aren't
even really good analogies for it
humanity is not based an issue like this
before which is why we're still around
and and I think looking at this that
this is just like clearly
beyond the reach of our present
civilization it's not close it's outside
the range of things that you could
reasonably that you could tell a
reasonable story about people doing
successfully
and and that's why we
we need to back off or rather I predict
that if we don't back off we die and I
wish we would back off I don't predict
that we will
well certainly there's no way to wrap up
such a dark vision in any way that is uh
going going to be satisfactory or
calming to the audience I think but that
being said
um Eliezer yardkowski is taking this
very seriously as the founder and Senior
research fellow of the machine
intelligence Research Institute and I
really do appreciate your time and
insights even if they are not optimistic
on this issue
thank you thanks for having me on
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show there is
one Republican running for the
nomination right now who's willing to
call out the obvious grift of Mega
cultists and others that has been
perpetrated by Donald Trump by Jared
Kushner by all the people around Donald
Trump and that one person is obviously
no I'm kidding it's Chris Christie okay
Chris Christie is the one guy that is
willing to say a number of different
things that are obvious uncontroversial
truths to anybody even remotely
connected to reality but it's only Chris
Christie who's willing to say it here is
Chris Christie on CNN last night saying
what the hell was Jared Kushner doing in
the Middle East what on Earth is going
on with these grifts and all of these
people monetizing their proximity to
power Trump himself not a single other
Republican candidate is talking about
these things listen to this let's
remember something he's a billionaire
he's a billionaire self-professed
billionaire why can't he use his own
money to pay his personal legal fees
because he's cheap and not use money
coming from the public it's disgraceful
and it's a continued grift and look the
Trump family has been involved in
grifting for quite some time he was
doing this in terms of the people who
got paid out of this pack before whether
it was Kimberly Guilfoyle or other the
the Trump charity I mean there's no
there's no end to the Grift remember
it's the family Jared Kushner six months
after he leaves the White House gets two
billion dollars from the Saudi The
Sovereign wealth fund yep when I haven't
here haven't heard Ronda sanctimonious
talking about that Trump had put him in
a position to be in the Middle East what
was Jared Kushner doing in the Middle
East better late than never folks we had
Rex Tillerson and Mike Pompeo as
secretaries of State we didn't need
Jared Kushner he was put there to make
those relationships and then he cashed
in on those relationships when he left
the office so what Donald Trump's doing
now is just the continuation of what
he's his family to do and to be clear
what Chris Christie's talking about is
that Trump is now fundraising for
illegal defense fund for all of these
different cases for all these different
indictments that he's facing and Chris
Christie is saying why why does he need
to fundraise for that he's so rich over
the entire course of his time as
president why do you think he's not
using his own money to pay for his legal
fee because he's the cheapest person
I've ever met in my life
that's why and and what he's very good
at Caitlyn is spending other people's
money right and if you look at his
history in New Jersey do you think he's
misleading vote his voters his
supporters by uh I think those
supporters you know write a check to
Trump for president they think they're
paying for campaign expenses not for
personal legal expenses now in Trump's
defense I don't even know that it's a
trump defense there are cultists so deep
in the cult that they are glad to pay
for Trump's legal defense because they
believe that the indictments are
political that it's actually Joe Biden
doing it and all these different things
so like there I I think Chris Christie
is right that there are some Trump
donors who think the money is being used
for the campaign there are some who know
it's being used for the legal defense
and are fine with that and there are
those who are in this position where
they believe that the legal defense is
kind of part of the campaign because the
indictments are part of the campaign
against Trump which is a crazy there's
no evidence of that whatsoever Chris
Christie was a defender of trump for a
long time and for that he you know I
think he always deserves to be
criticized at least he is saying this
stuff now and no other Republican
running in that primary is willing to do
it
um here is Chris Christie also most of
them won't talk about January 6th in
these terms either but even Mike Pence
won't talk about January 6th in these
terms and they wanted to kill Pence but
Chris Christie will talk about it good
for him exactly a strong statement
people were killed Caitlyn as you know
that day on Capitol Hill defending the
capital
um we had members of Congress who were
running for their lives we have people
trying to hunt down the vice president
of the United States Channing hang Mike
Pence right and Donald Trump the entire
time sat outside the Oval Office and
that little dining room his eating a
well done cheeseburger and watching TV
and doing nothing to stop what was going
on until it got to the point where even
he could no longer stand it and he
finally had four something in the
afternoon put out a video asking people
to leave the Capitol and Ron DeSantis
doesn't have any opinion on that
look I know by the way I'm pretty sure I
know who that high school student was he
goes to every town hall meeting in New
Hampshire he's been to three of mine and
he asked really tough questions and I
said to him the last time I tell how
many he was out of mind see if any of
the candidates will answer your
questions directly
um and grade them on it they won't they
won't so listen again we don't have to
now rehabilitate Chris Christie into
some hero
it is a very useful thing to see a
republican drop some truth bombs on
maggots or magedonians or megapotamians
I think that that is a good thing he
Chris Christie was complicit in the
Trump nonsense for years he stood behind
Trump and endorsed him in the the entire
thing and for that he deserves our
criticism and now he is the only guy
running in this primary who's willing to
say some of these things and so we can
praise that here's one more one more
clip
um about uh the January 6th stuff if he
asked
how would you answer it I would say it
was one of the most disgraceful days
in American history
and that the president was principally
responsible for it right one not a
single other Republican is willing to
say that through the conduct and his
words from election night forward
inciting people and insisting that the
election was stolen when it wasn't
through his speech that day when he
attacked directly his own vice president
and incited those people to be angry at
Mike Pence who was just performing his
constitutional Duty and he had no choice
in every lawyer good lawyer had told
people that that he couldn't do anything
different than that and then while the
event was going on while the riot was
going on on Capitol Hill we know that
Donald Trump was watching it and was
being urged by even members of his own
family to get out there and say
something and he refused
because he was enjoying watching people
yell scream and Destroy things in his
name this is all undeniably true and
Trump will never admit it and insists
that it's fake news Chris Christie
holding steady at 2.5
in the Republican primary the only guy
willing to tell these what should be
uncontroversial truths and uh if I had
to choose from the current Republican
slate who is the next president without
a doubt it would be Chris Christie let's
now go to someone very different than
Chris Christie and I'm talking about Ron
DeSantis Ron DeSantis put forth a plan
yesterday on Fox News so insane so
ridiculous and so deranged that even Fox
News host Martha McCallum is visibly
skeptical and obviously doesn't buy it
DeSantis was asked whether he wants to
eliminate any agencies and he mentioned
not only three entire agencies depart
Commerce energy and education but he
said he would eliminate the IRS which is
so ridiculous but then the thing he says
after that is almost worse take a listen
are you in favor of eliminating any
agencies I know conservatives in the
past have talked about closing the
Department of Education would you do
that
so we would do education we would do
Commerce we do energy and we would do
IRS and so if Congress will work with me
on doing that we'll be able to reduce
eliminate the size of scope of
government but what I'm also going to do
Martha is be prepared if Congress won't
go that far I'm going to use those
agencies to push back against woke
ideology and against the leftism that we
see creeping into all institutions of
American life so for example with
Department of Education we reverse all
the transgender sports stuff women's
sports should be protected we reverse
policies trying to inject the curriculum
into our schools that will all be gone
we will make sure we have an
accreditation system for higher ed which
is not trying to foment more things like
Dei and CRT so we'll be prepared to do
both uh either way it'll be a win for
conservatives imagine for a second if a
Democratic presidential candidate said I
will be using the IRS the Department of
Commerce the department of education and
the department of energy to destroy
conservatism imagine for a second if a
Democratic president ever said something
like that they would be calling for
their head they would be saying lock him
or her up Rick Wilson tweeted
uh I'll either eliminate these agencies
or use them to destroy my political
enemies set every authoritarian in the
history of ever this is outrageous this
is a dangerous extremist and by the way
give me a break dude this is in the
style of the Trump promises anyone with
any Common Sense knows it will never
happen he's not going to get rid
certainly he's not going to get rid of
the IRS and I don't think if he was
President he would get rid of the
Department of Education or the
Department of Commerce or the department
of uh energy which was the other one
this is sort of like Mexico is going to
build uh pay to build our wall across
the entire U.S Mexico border and I will
solve the U at the israeli-palestinian
conflict in my first term we all know
you're not doing any of that and after
the fact some people defend it by saying
well it was aspirational it's what he
wanted to do don't we want to hold our
presidential candidates in terms of the
promises they make at least to some
degree
to things that are remotely possible so
this reminds me of the classic moment
where Rick Perry during his failed bid
for the Republican Presidential
nomination also wanted to remove a bunch
of departments but forgot which ones
this is a classic and I will tell you
it's three agencies in government when I
get there that are gone is it Commerce
education and the uh what's the third
one there let's see
all five Okay so Commerce education and
uh the uh uh uh EPA EPA there you go
[Applause]
seriously
anyone you were talking about no sir no
sir we were talking about the agencies
of government the EPA needs to be
rebuilt I don't know remove them all but
you can't name the third one
third agency of government I would I
would do away with the education uh the
uh
Commerce and let's see I can't the third
sorry yeah
um listen they're not getting rid of any
of these things but they are
extraordinarily dangerous people and the
fact that DeSantis is willing to say
I'll get rid of the IRS what we of
course need to do if you actually want
to take seriously the idea of people who
are
um not paying their fair share and you
actually need to you need to scale up
the IRS you need to give the IRS the
resources to actually conduct Audits and
we know that the multiplier effect the
return on IRS audit agents to Target
extraordinarily High income individuals
is an extremely profitable thing
uh and as I've said before if you hire
an IRA IRS agent for 70 grand and
they're mostly auditing people making 30
grand even if those people underpaid
their taxes by 10 or 15 you're not going
to recover very much money
um but we know that uh the very rich
underpaid I don't mean underpay from a
political or moral standpoint I just
mean they're not paying what the law
currently says they should pay based on
the tax code it's not legal loopholes
it's not they're just they're just
putting in the wrong information they're
not paying what they should pay under
current law it's extremely profitable
from the standpoint of what you pay the
IRS agents versus what you end up
recovering and people who didn't pay
what they're supposed to pay that's the
direction we should go not getting rid
of the IRS but again it's another one of
these virtue signals IRS is now bad it's
political it's it's you know armed
agents blah blah blah uh Ronda santis
even if he becomes president is not
getting rid of the IRS we have a
voicemail number that number is 219 to
David P this is a heartwarming voicemail
it's very rare usually the voicemails
are like you Jew bastard I hate you Etc
this is a heartwarming voicemail
from a not a grandmother a great
grandmother that loves the show
I'm a 77 year old great grandma and I
love your show I watch it every single
day you have such a wonderful uh take on
what is going on in our world and
especially the political world and keep
up the good work I absolutely love it
thank you thank you folks this is what
we're trying to build everyone is
welcome here I hear from 15 year olds
when we take live calls that say they
are engaged in politics thanks to the
show and then we hear from great
grandmothers sweet great grandmothers
who also like what is going on
everybody's welcome here that's the
great thing about it unless you're a
Neo-Nazi then get the hell out unless
you're gonna change your views thanks to
me in which case you're no longer a
Neo-Nazi and you're welcome again all
right we have a great bonus show for you
today extraordinary bonus show a David
Pac-Man membership costs six bucks a
month okay Bill Cosby has been food by
nine more women are these also just made
up charge okay now we're going to talk
about the latest allegations against
Bill Cosby uh Joe Biden said something
very interesting he says that personally
he's not big on abortion because he's
Catholic but he believes we should have
Roe v Wade and that abortion should be
legal this is interesting because there
are so many layers to it that I want to
discuss and lastly I I love this you all
know I hate tipping I tip and I tip well
I hate that tipping is a thing okay just
price it and pay everybody a fair wage
and let's forget about tipping a new
Denver restaurant has eliminated tipping
has adjusted prices and is paying
everybody a living wage this is the
model okay this is the model we'll talk
about all of it on the bonus show sign
up at joinpackman.com I'll see you then
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors I will simply
never have time to read all of the
non-fiction books I'd like to read so I
use short form the world's best guide to
non-fiction books so I can learn more
faster unlike other platforms short form
provides valuable analysis chapter by
chapter to give you a deeper
understanding of the topic try it free
and get 25 off using my link below